Oh wow oh wow oh wow...
Hello hello hello hello I forgot that it does this.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
I blame you for my recent desire to play DMC4.
I've been playing hell and hell.
Good luck.
Thank you.
I need it today.
I guess I do.
I'm so... sleepy.
It's just like, thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you so much.
And just today you were the five gifts.
Dark Mint-chan.
Dark Mint-da.
Made licorice.
I felt like...
I felt like if I didn't look like the thumbnail, people would be like...
Scam!
I'm sorry if you're watching the VOD.
Sorry.
Oh gosh.
If you're watching the VOD...
This might not pertain to you so much, but...
I had to move the stream...
A couple hours because I so foolishly...
Scheduled... I had some voice recording stuff.
And if you call her stinky...
I see it, Ed.
I see it.
I was such a fool and I scheduled...
My voice recording stuff...
Well, okay.
I thought it was something else that I was scheduling.
And I was like, oh, that thing needs less time.
And I thought I scheduled the voice stuff for tomorrow.
But I didn't.
And... yeah, so...
We're here.
And I recorded and I'm...
So tired.
I might take Sunday off, you guys.
No, I won't.
It's just The Sims.
It's my favorite Friday from Mint's DMC.
The Friday.
Oh yeah, Evanescence.
I haven't watched the video though for Evanescence.
The new DMC anime, right?
And Evanescence does a song for it.
Saki, thanks for the gift!
Thank you.
My throat after recording... Oh, it actually hurts so much.
It actually hurts so much, but it's not because I...
You know, I talk all the time.
I stream all the time and everything.
But ever since... Ever since...
Spring!
And all the pollen!
It started, my throat started hurting in Japan from all the pollen.
Minky will be cringe again.
Yeah!
Why are calendars... Wait, why are calendars... Oh, I thought you were saying I will be cringe.
Why are calendars so lucky?
Because they have so many dates!
Offering for me to the Oracle of Tomodachi Life.
Looking forward to those dreams.
But yeah, ever since the pollen started coming out...
When I was in Japan, things started blooming.
And when I got back to my maid cafe, things were blooming and I was like...
So much pollen!
And it's stuck in my throat!
And so, it hurts a little bit.
But it's not because of recording.
The time has come and so has pollen.
I know.
Goth Minto.
Save me, Goth Minto.
So edgy.
Is this the first time you've had black hair?
No!
This is probably what I would look like if I were alive, maybe.
Probably, no?
Instead of white hair?
Probably.
I imagine.
We'll just pretend, right?
Maybe.
Today I'm cosplaying as a human being.
But Nero has white hair.
Maybe I should change.
No.
Ok, then today is special.
Sorry, I'm feeling so...
Oh gosh, I can't stop yawning.
So sleepy.
It might be a bit of a shorter stream because I started later than I anticipated.
I'm so, so sorry.
But we'll have more Devil May Cry next week.
So, the schedule change worked perfectly for me because I had a work meeting at the original time.
Oh, O2 Revel!
It's ok, it's all good, thank you.
Thank you for understanding, everybody.
Severus, it's your birthday!
Alright, we'll sing happy birthday and then we'll start, yeah?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday...
Oh no, there you are.
Oh dear, Severus.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Salken, thank you.
Alright, go again.
Thank you for the pig.
Thank you!
Take care of yourself.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
So...
What was I going to say?
I don't know how much we'll get through today.
Who knows, maybe I'll have like a burst of energy in the middle.
But right now it's not looking very likely.
I can't stop, I'm sorry.
Contagious yawning, I know.
I know.
A lot of us are emotionally drained from yesterday.
People said that I streamed three times yesterday, but I consider it more like two streams.
Because it's like...
All I did was watch the direct.
Let's go back to this costume, since we did the other one before.
There is a black haired Dante, but we don't talk about him.
Dante?
Nero?
Gotta pay the QEI tech.
Don't say yawn.
I'll yawn.
Don't say lazy.
Mimped.
Okay.
Oh that's right, our girlfriend got stolen.
And...
We learned the devil form last time, which is great.
But time has come, it's over.
Bye.
Take care of yourself.
I will, I am.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm all good.
Oh, that was it.
Mission, wrapped in glory.
Find the ambitions of His Holiness.
What?
Are we gonna go get our girlfriend back?
Oh yeah.
Why?
Oh, this thing is like, got a little...
It's got a little...
I'm now addicted to bloons.
I can't get the monkeys off my mind.
Good.
Okay, these don't seem to do anything.
Do I fall in here?
Nope.
Alright, I guess we leave.
I'm finding the Holiness' ambitions.
Thank you.
That doesn't seem very good.
Oh!
Wiz, this is very... What is... What are you?
He's so calm, he's so cool.
He's so collected.
He doesn't care that his girlfriend just got stolen.
Thank you so much for the five.
He's like, yeah, I don't have time for witty yaps right now.
Oh shoot.
What?
Oh jeez.
Okay, and... Wait, double... Ah, there we go.
No!
Where are you going?
Nero!
Oh, they disappear and it's so frustrating.
This is a great time to remember how to play this game.
Did I just parry that?
Maybe I'm cracked.
Oh, I didn't parry that.
Ouch!
Come on!
Oh shoot.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh, why do you disappear?
Ah, ouch.
I tried dodging it.
I saw it coming.
I saw it coming!
I didn't see that one coming.
Wait, what did I forgore?
What do you mean I forgore?
Oh, snatch!
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I did forgo...
Ouch.
I totally forgore.
That's right!
These guys are the little...
Actually, I didn't recognize that they were those thingies.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, can you...
I didn't recognize it was the ugly lizards.
Yeah,
they look like little... I mean they are pretty ugly, no?
Where are you at?
Where did he go?
Come here!
Oh, I got him!
Where did you go?
He's...he's...he's dead!
Whoa!
I always told myself I'd send her red when she max exceed or SSS, whichever came first.
Thank you for all the wonderful DFC streams.
Hope you know you're super smug and sexy.
And you always max exceed our expectations.
Also, sword, trick, gun, royal guard!
Thank you!
We got a puzzle.
I'm super smug and sexy, really.
Oh shoot, it's this thing again.
I'm running.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, I'm gonna...I'm gonna miss it.
Oh, she used the camera.
Wait, hold on.
Can I have...Oh, ouch.
Um...
Can we do that again?
Uh-oh.
Am I...am I locked?
Wait.
What was the camera?
Yeah, exactly!
Uh...uh...
Uh...
Little turn.
Thank you.
To the right?
What do you mean to the right?
Is there one right here?
No.
Time to go back.
I have to cross through again though.
I guess it's...
OK.
Alright, let's not get hit.
There we go.
I made it.
Somehow.
Ta-da!
Wow, cool puzzle.
I sure hope I didn't need anything up there.
By your hand you cannot break our clasp.
Stop.
Oh, um...
Oh!
I forgot.
I was like, how do I activate it?
I was like, do I...
Hmm...
I know there was some like blorbs and stuff up there.
I guess we missed it.
I guess I missed it.
So sad.
But we got some rorbs.
I'll take it.
Oh!
Wait, I can recall it though.
Should I do... Wait, will I have to fight everything all over again?
No.
Wait.
I thought I saw a door.
Maybe.
I think I just locked myself in.
Oh!
No!
No,
please.
Nero.
Straight.
Please!
Yeah, but like, can I get back down?
Do I have to go all the way back to the top?
Oh!
Jeez.
Don't make me...
I'm doing all this for nothing, aren't I?
Oh wait, no.
It's right here.
I can dive back down.
But I want the... I want that blorb.
I want this.
How do I get to it?
Thank you so much for the 20 gets.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
How many blorb slots do I have anyway?
I have one out of four.
It is a mystery.
He's right there within my grasp, but actually not really.
Just barely within my grasp.
If I go in here...
If I go in there, we'll go up.
Turn like a bit to the right.
I give up.
Onwards.
Oh, it's these guys again.
How did I make it through?
You... you ass!
Oh no.
Gosh!
Run!
OK, they're all gonna jump at me.
Jump at me!
Come here!
Again?
Oh my gosh.
Wow!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
You guys are gonna die!
Ouch!
No!
Same time.
How romantic.
Oh, not run.
I can't tell if I'm going the correct way, but...
I can't think of another way I gotta go.
Oh, that's right.
We came from the lasers.
Did I do this one?
I thought I did.
I do respawn.
Oh, do I get more stuff?
I'm gonna try it anyway.
It's good practice, no?
Yeah,
yeah.
No reason not to get paid.
Pretty much, no?
Was there anything else on this side?
You're holy.
Oh, that's right.
Oh wait, what's here?
Hello?
More money.
OK.
Alright, we're gonna go through.
I'm gonna make it.
And I'm also gonna get paid while I do it.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, that was so close.
That's right.
We open this up.
Oh, cinematic.
Happy...Celibacy week?
Today is my birthday!
Is that...Jesus Christ?
Your name is cut off though.
Can I get a birthday song?
The hell?
Isn't that Christmas?
Happy Demon Hunting Winter.
Thank you for the...
Thank you so much for the 500.
Thank you.
It's Christmas.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Jesus Christ.
Happy birthday.
OK,
I don't like that.
I hate chairs.
Alright.
This looks so awful.
Excuse me?
I'm gonna wait for it to reset.
Oh, nice.
This is a fun room.
Fun is subjective, no?
Oh, this actually lasts a long time.
OK, good.
It will stop though, right?
Eventually?
I was just gonna wait for it to reset.
Wow.
How long is this room?
I guess I'll go.
And really regret it.
I think I'm gonna die here.
No?
If I go and it resets in the middle, I'm definitely gonna die.
OK, I'm just gonna go.
Ouch!
Ouch you!
OK.
Oh!
Wait, what's glowing?
Why is it glowing?
Oh, there is a secret here.
What's the secret mission?
First try, baby.
First try.
Vermifuge.
Eliminate all the Chimera before the Scarecrow was taken over.
I think I'm OK.
This one.
Is this mission.
It's a bodyguard mission?
Screw this mission.
I think right now, if I were in a better head space, maybe...
Oh my goodness.
If I were better in... Wait, what?
Oh, it's down there.
Wow, that's so rude.
They force you.
No!
Wise choice.
Oh, you!
Come here.
He's not even gonna let it get up.
There we go.
Where are you?
Don't
even get up.
Don't even try.
Don't even...
You will never see the light of day ever again.
I will not let you even get a single breath.
Ouch.
We're back?
OK.
Did you guys see how... Did you guys see him just funny run at me?
It was so funny.
Ouch.
Shall we dance?
Nice.
Can I please hit you?
What happened?
No, so unfair.
Please.
Ouch.
I hate this guy.
I can't grab him.
At least I don't think I can.
I don't wanna get too far though, because he starts getting crazy.
You can?
Maybe a ton of times?
Oh, I see him.
He's becoming naked.
He's losing his clothes.
Oh my god.
You guys, I think I'm gonna die.
I think I'm gonna die for real.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh god.
Oh god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Ah!
Where will I start from I wonder.
Abandon all hope.
Oh from here is not so bad maybe.
It's not so bad maybe from here.
Oh, oh jeez.
Don't, don't look.
Don't look.
Did you guys see that?
That was crazy at the end.
Sorry I wasn't looking.
Good, good, good, good.
Nero Snatch couldn't get his clothes off fast enough.
Become naked, naked, naked, naked, naked.
I'm gonna do the same exact thing I did before.
Oh wait, no, no, no.
That's not the same exact thing.
I wanted to put them in the corner.
Yeah, there we go.
Rorbs be damned I guess.
Killing is more important.
You're close.
Yeah, that's right.
It's someone's birthday.
I will have to say happy birthday.
Just remind me.
I tried to dodge.
If I, if I snatch while, while I'm in.
Oh, there we go.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, we did big damage though.
That was too slow.
Taking your clothes, taking your clothes.
You're naked, you're naked.
When you get the chance, could you please wish my friend Jack a happy birthday?
We love you, PewDiePie.
Thank you, Ellie.
Of course I can wish Jack a happy birthday.
Jack, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Jack.
Happy birthday.
Okey dokey.
There is nothing else, so let's attempt this.
Oh, the key of Kronos is beginning to vibrate in resonance with the machine.
You use the key of Kronos.
Okay.
The time has come, so have I.
Wait, do I have to get back up?
Wait, that's a different door.
Okay.
Okay, we can...we'll be able to do this.
Surely.
Wait, where is the next one?
Can I get there?
Alright Nero, I'm going to need you to use your arms, buddy.
Oh gosh, okay.
So far so good.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, it's just a staircase.
Oh...
Okay, we got this.
This time for sure.
Is it this door?
Please, no Nero!
I'm just going to wait.
Again, again!
Come here.
You're not allowed to rest.
I won't let you.
Please, Nero, please!
I won't mind if my birthday comes.
When your birthday is here, I will sing you happy birthday.
That's how it works.
Why am I so bad at this?
Are you going to try the other character playthroughs?
I'm not sure yet.
Wait, where is it?
Where is the thingy?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I'm not sure.
I think it might depend on how...
I feel.
Nice, nice!
We got it!
O, U.
Oh, U, W.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
And smash him, smash him, smash him, smash him.
Grab him, grab him, grab him, smash him, grab him.
Grab your shield, grab your shield.
Come here.
Stupid.
Come here, come here.
You missed your birthday 9.
How could you?
Oh, another?
Another?
I'll grab these in a second.
Oh, there's two more?
Where did you come from?
No, my rorbs!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, what happened?
Why did it break?
It didn't count?
It's so sad.
Ladies, ladies.
It's time from the first hit.
I didn't mean to hit it the first time I did.
My birthday is on April 1st.
My mom's April Fool.
Is that what she called you growing up?
Your mommy's little April Fool.
What is this?
Oh, the winged talisman is beginning to vibrate in resonance with the machine.
You used the winged talisman.
I'm already missing it.
I want to have another one.
Blorb!
I saw it.
Wait, go back down.
Go down, go down!
The blorb!
I saw it.
I'm greedy, please.
I'm so greedy.
Down, down.
No going back?
How are you even supposed to know it's there?
How are you even supposed to know?
Ladies, ladies.
Anything over here?
Nothing?
OK.
This isn't a door, right?
Gotta replay the whole game.
Meeting room.
This looks like a boss room, no?
Two of you!
No, no!
Come
here.
Oh, damn.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I saw your shadow.
I don't think I can...
Well, I was...
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can I do it when I'm in Mega 4?
Oh, no.
Maybe?
There
we go.
Oh my goodness.
You should have a preliminary sense of where all the blorbs are.
I'm a failure!
Chair, chair, chair.
Nice!
Glorb.
Delicious, delicious, delicious glorb.
Oishii!
Wait.
This looks pretty ominous, no?
Is this about to be a boss battle?
Those were Herman Miller!
What's this one?
Secret mission.
Free running.
Reach the goal without falling through the vanishing floor.
No.
How about...no.
What was it that I was saving up for, I wonder?
When Devil Trigger is active, press...
Y, B.
The one you cheesed, but this time you cannot cheese.
Exactly, so I will not try.
What are they doing?
Kissing?
I could also...whoops, not Devil Trigger.
I could also start doing charge shot.
I could maybe get all of charge shot.
Encounter the night guys by timing your busters.
They're about to attack, but it's pretty difficult.
I see.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't they kind of look like they're kissing?
Maybe not.
Maybe my own delusions.
I think my delusions are happening.
I've never used that one.
I tried using that one and I'm so bad at it.
Split.
Mid-air, press R, B, forward.
I think you're kissing wrong.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Just some guy with a mustache.
I saw you.
I saw your comment.
Where were you?
I think it was on the Tomodachi Life trailer...
Video that Nintendo posted.
And I was like, hey!
I know that guy!
He's everywhere!
He gets around all the chats?
Are you that famous?
All the comments were like that too.
They were like, oh my gosh, I've seen this guy before.
My Nerissa guys, wait.
Stop.
I wish I was half as beautiful as her.
He's everywhere.
My secret's out.
I was like, hey!
I know that guy!
It's always funny when I see people in chat that I recognize in other places and I'm like...
Sometimes I'll see you in other VTuber chats.
But that would never be you, right?
You know?
I met a fellow Wisp today.
Wisp, you know who you are.
I cheat on you all the time?
Why would you tell me this?
Yeah, I only mean to...
Thank god you never watch Twitch.
I do watch Twitch, I just don't chat.
I watch a bunch of streams.
Well, not a bunch, but I watch streams.
I just don't chat.
And then Kiara gets upset at me for it, so I try to chat.
But then sometimes I don't chat.
Don't tell her.
Don't tell her that I watch her streams and don't chat.
I dread the days Miki discovers my AMVs?
I'm a lurker.
I'm just a lurker, okay?
I'm just a lurker.
Let me lurk.
Let me just...
Let me be unnoticed.
I'm just haunting, okay?
Gosh.
Let me just lurk.
Okay, we won't tell her.
I don't trust you at all, Spank.
I don't trust you at all.
I'm mostly a lurker too.
Lurking is fine.
Hello lurkers.
Hello everybody lurking watching.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Speaking of Kiara, when's your RTX stream?
You know, I tried it.
I tried making one of me.
And I was like, I don't think this looks good.
So I just...
I was like, I can't make it look like me at all.
I couldn't make it look like me at all.
I have been summoned.
Guys, it's my first stream here.
Shut up, Evan.
It's not your first stream.
Shut up.
Okay, anyway.
Abilities?
Are there any abilities?
What's a table hopper?
Just before an attack hits, press R.
Oh, sideways.
I never press sideways.
After executing a table hopper, press R.
Oh my gosh.
You just dance around with them.
After executing a table hopper 2.
Wait, this is so confusing.
Press LT just after an attack.
Wouldn't that activate my devil trigger?
Your timing must be absolutely perfect.
Get more orbs.
That's huge.
Enemy step.
I love this one.
Pull my mental trigger.
Oh, LT.
Not LB.
Oh, you're right.
Press LT just after an attack.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh yeah, because there is a gauge.
It's the rev thing.
What if I try my gun?
I'm going to try it.
We can always...
No, not you.
We can always refund.
Oh my bad.
There we go.
It's time for big charge action.
It's just range of orb collection.
It's a scam.
No.
It's real to me.
OK
I know there is going to be a boss in there.
Your holiness?
Oh Dante!
It was like a little tap.
No, my rubbing sword.
My stand has words to say about that.
Oh, our sword that we just got.
Return it to me.
And I'll let you go, kid.
I want to see his ass turn pink.
Oh my god.
He is so calm.
Wait, Dante.
I don't want to fight you.
Oh shit.
I have to fight Dante.
Oh, he is
too fast.
Oh my god.
He is too fast.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Dante, please.
Don't.
Dante, that's my move.
Please.
Oh my god.
He is so good.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
He is parrying my bullets.
Where are my bullets?
How are you so fast?
Oh my god.
Now I learned what to do.
No.
How are you dodging so fast?
Oh
my god.
Stop it.
He is gobbling.
Here we go.
Grab you.
Oh shit.
We grabbed him.
This is too much.
Ouch.
I
think I can do this.
Damn.
He dodged.
Oh my god.
Where are my...
Trickster.
Holy shit.
Ouch.
Come on.
Please let me out.
I want off this wild ride.
Jesus.
The camera angle scared me.
We are so dead.
Please let me out.
Oh shit.
Please.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
No.
Stop.
Please.
I wonder if I have any.
I have an M-Star.
It's a fun fight.
It's not bad at all.
It's fun for real.
Let's try it one more time.
Let's try it one more time and see.
Oh damn.
Damn.
We were so close.
That wasn't bad.
For a first try.
OK.
Let's go.
I'm here.
Oh god.
He keeps spamming this move.
Don't say no.
Oh my god.
He is so dirty.
Ouch.
How do you get out of that?
It hurts so bad.
Oh my god.
He always gets me back.
Too good.
Please grab him.
Grab him.
I'm doing way worse this time than before.
Dante.
I think I'm ready to give up.
Just kill me.
Just kill me Dante.
I wasn't feeling it.
Just kill me.
I can totally see with this camera.
Alright.
For real this time.
Let me get some water.
Complete lack of motivation.
I even have a sword.
Where is your motivation?
You are scaring me Dante.
You are scaring me.
Why do you got to get me like that?
Stop spamming that.
Are you about to do that?
No?
OK.
I hide.
Shoot!
No!
No shoot!
Oh my goodness.
Come here Dante.
Come here.
Shall we dance?
What's the point?
I can't even get a hit in.
Oh shoot.
Please.
What's the point if I can't get a hit in?
This sucks.
Oh that sucks.
Oh that really sucks.
Oh that really, really sucks.
That really, really sucks.
Is there more heal?
Don't do it.
Don't you dare.
OK.
I'm gonna heal my DT.
Oh he is too far away for DT.
How did I get so close?
Beginner's luck I guess.
Holy moly.
No, no, no.
You
gotta get out of it.
You gotta get out of it.
He stingered me and I didn't even stinger him.
That's messed up.
Don't, don't, don't you dare.
Don't you...
What?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I thought I was behind the pole.
The way he runs at me scares me.
He's got like a craze.
Look at his eye.
I can't read him at all.
I'm so bad.
Dante's ranking looks like during this fight.
What pots?
Are these pots?
No, it's worms.
Stay away from me Dante, you crazy man.
Stop it.
Don't follow me.
Dante don't follow me.
You are insane.
Dante!
He is chasing me.
He is such a freak.
OK.
Alright, alright.
Come here.
After you do your little thing.
OK.
Come here.
Oh shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I even grabbed him.
Why did I run?
He taunted me.
Stop doing that.
Don't do that.
That's weird.
Dante, don't do that.
I don't like that.
What did you say?
What did you say grandpa?
Oh shoot.
Oh no.
That's so unfair.
Dante.
Excuse me.
What are you doing?
What is that?
Ouch.
I parried him though.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
He is styling on me.
Ouch.
Yeah, you missed.
Oh nevermind.
You didn't miss.
I missed.
And that's it.
I should have healed the first time you guys.
Why?
I was such an idiot.
I should have healed.
I should have healed the first time.
Oh my god.
I'm such an idiot.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid.
I think
I had literal beginner's luck.
Shooting is the key here.
Damn.
Ouch, ouch.
He got me first.
Ouch.
It really isn't.
Ok, well, it is for me, ok?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
It like kind of stuns lock him.
Stun locks him, you know?
And so, I can kind of like get him where I need to be.
See?
It's working for me.
It's working for me!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, no.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
That was so sick, though.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I need to get away from him.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, hold on.
What are you doing?
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
No!
Don't stinger, please.
Don't stinger.
No, no, no, no.
It's so loud in my ears.
What did you do just now?
Oh shoot.
That was close.
Ouch.
Damn it, damn it, damn it.
Oh shoot.
No, he got me first.
I might heal, guys.
I might.
I love DMC2, baby.
Holy cow, Alante.
Where did you learn that?
Definitely not from me.
Ouch.
Oh no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Should I heal?
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
One HP in a dream.
I think I'm gonna use it.
I'm gonna use it.
Okay, doctor.
Alright.
Oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't like it.
I'm gonna waste my DT.
I'm gonna waste my DT reel.
What a waste.
No, my DT.
DT.
You're so close.
Oh my god.
He's so close.
He's so stinking close.
DMC2.
Hey, if it works, it works.
My methods may be unconventional, but...
But if it works for me, it works.
I need water back.
It's gotta stay in the family.
The family.
Wait, then where's Virgil?
I need this.
I need...
Save your girlfriend.
No one can stop her to join.
Thank you.
Now that you're calm and cool...
Get going.
I killed him in DMC1.
Oh, the timeline.
You're right.
Hey.
What's your name?
Nero.
You're Dante, right?
Not a bad name.
Neither is yours.
Where the hell...
Ma'am?
She's styling.
That regal look suits you.
Oh my god!
It's been her the whole time.
It's been Trish the whole time.
Damn.
Mom?
Wait.
Why is she so young?
Then I'll just have to kick his ass.
My mom is so hot!
Well, not my mom anymore.
I'm Nero now.
Yeah, um, shut up game.
Wait, did I get any skill points for that?
DDs.
Wow, she's got a...
That's what Trish has.
A couple pair of...
Wow.
S rank orb finder.
That's my only mission in my afterlife.
Prevent the birth of god?
But I already wished him happy birthday.
I'm gonna buy...
Some more stars.
Wait.
Oh yeah, I'm already maxed out on blue orbs.
That's so sad.
We are close to more orb.
Maybe I'll save it.
Shadow, Latina was fake.
Trish, of course it was a fake.
The cloth she pulls across herself to change clothes is more fabric than either of her outfits combined.
Yeah, where did it come from?
Just one vital star is a treat?
Oh my gosh, sorry guys, the pollen is actually kicking my butt.
Don't stand in my way.
It's your birthday.
You can do whatever you want.
The music is how midstream feels.
Thanks, acceptable casualty.
I mean, causality.
I'll be right back.
Yeah,
I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be super, super fast.
How many people get that name wrong?
I only know one person that reads worse than I do.
And her name is Mataracon.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Guys, my cat looked so cute right now.
It was really hard to leave.
I gave her a big ol' smooch on the head.
The roach has christened me causality.
Wait, it actually says causality.
It was cut off, so I thought it said casualty.
I didn't realize you changed it.
It was cut off in the super chat, so I thought it was...
Maybe I'm the bad reader then.
Wait, it still said...
Oh, it does say casualty.
I can't read.
I can't read!
Bring back glasses, Vito.
I love my illiterate OC.
Oh my goodness.
That was funny.
Okay, I will save the star.
We'll save up for a plorb instead.
Oh wait, was there anything...
Oh wait, not item.
Scale out.
How much do we have?
3000?
Okay, mission start!
We're gonna prevent the birth of a god.
It's okay, we can't read either.
We just mash the keys.
The only woman to gaslight in absentia.
Whoa, advent chamber.
I don't need the glasses.
Don't tell me what to do.
What's this?
I see.
Nice.
Whoa, big area.
You nasty little creature, you.
Yeah, you deserve your butt to be beaten up.
Yeah, you deserve that.
You deserve your butt to be...
Nasty bugs, you.
Disgust me.
Oh wait, it's the hot man.
So have I.
This time has immediately...
Wait, the time has immediately rolled over and gone to sleep?
Wait.
What's that?
Hot man.
Come here.
Oh, we got hollowed each other.
I'm trying to...
Nice.
Where are you?
Where's your clothes?
Oh, what the?
What?
What happened?
Slam dunk!
And three shot!
What just happened to you?
Taking your clothes and stripping you.
Stripping you bare.
Easy.
Delayed explosion.
Charge 3 has a delayed explosion.
I see.
I see, I see.
What is this for?
What, is there going to be a tricky blorb here too?
I don't think there's anything on that side.
I might be wrong, but...
I can explore real quick.
Just look around.
Oh, there's a skill issue, man.
Wait, do I have to get a smoking style here?
Do I have to get a smoking style?
Yes?
I don't think that's possible for me.
We're out of atomic though.
Gotta have!
Get lost!
Oh my gosh, it's so tricky.
There we go.
Oh...
Oh my goodness.
It's too difficult.
Can you taunt the statue?
I don't think so.
Other combos I have?
I sold the ball.
Maybe if I did have the other combos I'd be able to do it.
Nice!
Oh, shoot.
Almost so close.
I think I need to also hit in the air.
No, dang it.
I'm so used to it.
Oh my goodness.
I did it again!
What's wrong with me?
There we go.
So close!
Please!
I don't know, guys.
ZT?
Can I?
Is this a waste of my ZT?
I
don't know, guys.
I just can't get high enough.
I can't get close enough!
Why doesn't he jump anymore?
There we go.
Mash LT.
Charge shot.
Wait, charge shot while...
Charge shot while attacking?
I can do that?
Wait.
I can't.
I'm losing
it!
No!
No, I'm going to lose it.
Wait.
Wait, I lost it though.
I'm charging.
It like exploded.
Oh, is it delayed?
I might give up, you guys.
I'm trying to do the rev in between attacks, but...
I'm not doing it very well.
Rev!
I give up.
I don't think I have enough combos.
Like every time I get close, it's just not close enough.
It's OK.
I don't want to waste so much time there anyway.
We got close.
It's OK.
What's that?
There's somebody.
Oh, hello.
What's this?
Proceeding alone is strictly prohibited.
You can't touch me.
Yeah, I can't say I didn't try.
So true.
I like thought the rev was like...
Like you 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2 on the LT, you know?
But I guess I don't quite understand it.
That's OK.
It's an advanced technique.
Yeah.
Wait a second.
I just...
Portal?
Actually, I have two default combos.
It's OK.
I really don't want to waste a lot of time on it, but thank you.
Do I... Oh, do I have to summon... Wait.
I can't go alone.
Do I have to summon my...
My guy?
Shall we dance?
Come here.
Oh, never mind.
I just have to pull him in.
You're my date.
Catch this!
I thought I was going to have to summon my DT.
I didn't realize that it was a...
A, you know, activated by the other lever.
Oh, we got it?
What are you glowing for?
How did you know?
That was my favorite thing.
No!
Where am I?
Oh no.
I'm lost.
Can I get to the other side?
Is that not where the gorb...
Gorb is?
Whatever.
Vroom vroom.
That's what I did.
I made it.
That was a porb, no?
Wait, this is huge.
A devil star.
You're punishing me for getting the porb.
Or the devil star.
Don't be like this.
Oh damn!
Why aren't you fighting back?
You scared of me?
Nice thrusting.
I'm basically a master at this point.
Can I get that orb?
You're not gonna...
OK.
I do need to go over here actually.
Oh shoot.
This isn't the gold guy, is it?
I can't tell actually.
Maybe it is.
Yes it is!
Yeah, try.
Everybody is testing me.
Easy mode.
No!
Maybe I shouldn't have grabbed that gorb.
Stupid!
OK.
I get it.
They are so obsessed with me!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
OK, fine.
You guys leave me no choice.
Oh damn.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
That's what I tried doing before, but...
Oh shoot.
Ouch!
I should have just dodged it.
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone!
My orbs!
No!
Oh my goodness.
You are annoying.
There is such a pain in my side.
OK, finally we got rid of one guy.
One guy has been defeated.
Yeah!
Suplex!
Thank you guys for explaining.
I could only read part of the super chat.
But yeah, revving is kind of...
I try, if I can, remember or you know, whatever.
But it's not gonna be a main focus.
A lot of people were saying in comments before that...
It's kind of like...
For your first ever time playthrough, you don't really have to worry about it.
It's nice if you do it.
But yeah, I'm not gonna be like...
What to?
Yeah, so...
Hello?
What did this activate?
Did I activate it already?
What did you activate?
Oh, I already activated it?
The elevator.
The one next to the divinity statue?
OK.
I saw it showed me something, but I was also looking at you.
What a foolish thing for me to do.
Oh my god.
You again?
You guys are so... OK.
Yeah.
Why two of you?
Why?
Why two?
Please.
Why are there two of you?
Oh my gosh.
Just book it?
So true.
I'm gonna leave.
It's only curious.
All good.
There's lots of ways to play the game.
So of course everyone's gonna have their preferred style.
It looks like the lady...
from Kill la Kill.
The mob?
Are you God?
Oh!
My girlfriend!
No!
Oh my god.
Is she the god?
Chariot.
I don't think we're at that stage yet.
We need to get past hand holding first.
Get sucked back into the egg.
Oh my god.
He has a blue archive.
OK.
Alright.
Boss fight.
OK.
Let's see.
What?
How do we...
Alright mister.
OK.
How do I...
Is there only two of them?
We need the lock on for this fight.
OK.
You snatch.
I want that thing.
No.
Change!
No!
Please!
Can I have it?
It's in your bubble.
Damn.
That hurts bad.
Oh my god.
Please!
I... Hold on.
I clearly don't know how to change targets.
Because it's not L3.
What is it?
R3.
OK.
It's not R3.
Oh god.
OK.
Hold on.
I'm going to have to just...
I mean, obviously I'm going to have to read in this fight, but...
Sounds like he kind of sometimes says vocals vintage.
Which is pretty funny.
Wait.
Oh shit.
Move the stick when targeting?
That's kind of what's kicking my ass right now.
Hello?
Let's not press the stick.
Yeah.
I tried that.
Let's try it again.
OK.
Ah.
Pressing only changes?
This sucks.
OK.
Grab is huge in this.
Oh shit.
I think I'm on phase 2.
Elder abuse.
I miss beating up the old man.
Oh no.
Old man.
I prefer beating you up instead of this.
Um...
I much prefer that.
Oh.
Seriously?
Ouch.
Shit.
For
the savior!
Oh god.
I just had a feeling that would happen, but...
Yeah.
Why can't I grab sometimes?
Oh shit.
Nah.
Get to his ass.
No!
Oh god.
The second phase sucks.
I know I'm just kind of...
There we go.
No!
More power of the savior, please!
I don't know if that actually does anything, but...
Please.
Oh my gosh.
I did not dodge that one, but that's OK.
I can't seem to...
Get him back to...
To a point where I can...
You know?
Every time!
Just use holy water?
For real?
I know this doesn't do anything, but I don't care!
Oh, charge shoot.
Oh, I don't think I can.
Oh, maybe.
Ouch!
OK, die.
Oh, please!
Please!
Oh shit!
Shit!
This sucks!
I don't know how to change...
Targets.
I don't know how to change targets.
Yeah, I do have max snatch.
I do.
You don't need.
But when I'm trying to grab the other thing...
It's cheap, so I'm just gonna buy it.
It wasn't with L3 either when I tried it before.
At least the first part isn't so bad.
Second phase sucks though.
Come here!
No, no, no, no!
I messed up!
Oh shoot!
Please, can you?
There we go.
Please, grab him!
You are the demon, not me!
You tell him Nero!
You tell him!
There we go.
Yeah!
Alright, phase 2.
I'm
nervous.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
No!
No more power!
No power!
No power, please!
Oh shoot!
I almost dodged that, but not quite.
Oh my goodness, no!
Please!
Oh, this fight is hard.
Oh shoot!
No!
I was so close!
Shoot the fireballs!
I know!
I was trying!
Oh shoot!
Nice!
Oh my god!
He keeps doing the stupid power of the savior!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, buster the punch?
Oh shoot.
I didn't realize what he was.
Please!
I just DT'd.
Wait, this is buster, right?
I don't think I did it right.
I forgot to lock on.
Ouch!
Do it early?
OK.
Oh this fight.
I shoot!
But I...
There we go.
So do it early?
Like now?
When he says do it now, do I do it now?
Do I do it when he says do it now?
Is he the one backseating me?
Is he backseating me and I...
I wonder if I can chip him down a little bit more before he gets to second phase.
If I can chip him down a little bit more before I psycho mode DT, I wonder if I can get him way lower.
You can't skip the second phase.
Buster needs to be out before the punch.
Pitch perfect timing.
Nice.
I'll
try to knock the fist back.
I'll do my best you guys.
I'll do my best.
Come here.
Stop running away.
Alright, I'm gonna do this and then...
I'm gonna DT unless he...
Unless he goes to the guy.
We'll see.
Okay.
Now I just gotta do it one more time.
Can I get to you, mister?
Here we go.
Now this should get his health way further down.
Oh, not as far as I thought.
Shoot while punching?
You can spam...
Gosh, I always... Thank you for the reminder.
I forgot about that.
About the same.
Yeah, about the same.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I did it.
Oopsie.
Okay.
Alright.
I did it!
I did it first try!
Oh my gosh!
That was so clean!
That was so...
Oh my gosh!
We did it!
Thank you guys for the hand.
It did feel good.
It felt so good.
Where did Nero come from?
Who is this guy?
No!
No, not the sword!
And I don't actually answer that.
Yeah, smiley face.
No...
Oh.
The brother.
Credit card.
Oh no!
Kevin!
Credo!
Shoot, I can't remember this guy's name.
Kitty.
Yeah, true.
So...
Oh no!
Crap!
Dante!
Holy Trish and her Trishes.
Credit card was implied.
Oh yeah!
Snatch!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
Not the yaoi man.
So melodramatic.
What's happening to him?
He's turning into dust.
I think I love Nero.
He's got so much sass.
The middle fingers he got absorbed.
It's too good.
Says Dante.
Pot calling the kettle black, huh?
She's not gonna transform into something ugly.
She's gonna transform into one of those creepy things.
Time to...
Become one, huh?
No!
Kitty!
Oh baby, he's crying!
Oh,
the meat.
That's what's inside there?
That's nasty.
Dogs
He's so stupid.
Nah, I don't think so.
Yamato
Yeah, he knows.
He knows.
Stinking crap-o mansplaining to us.
He's really bleeding out.
Character change?
Don't get up!
Please.
Honor one last request.
Save them.
Kitty A and Nero.
Why does he gotta honor your request?
I don't know either.
He's such a sob.
It's cool, but stick to the plan.
Hot mama.
God dang.
So we...the character switch?
I only got 62% of orbs.
I'm losing my touch.
I'm losing my touch everybody.
Oh, Hojo.
Real?
Physically?
I got ears and fang.
Fang one.
I don't remember his name actually.
Anus?
That's not his name.
Oh, Angus Beef.
That's right.
Guys, I think it's starting to get serious.
Guys, I think it's starting to get real serious.
Trish, I need...Oh my god, no.
No, please god, no.
I can only grabby grab so much.
Trish, I need you to do your job.
Oh my gosh.
No!
These guys are the worst.
Nobody wants to deal with these guys.
I'll miss you if you don't have your Assassin's Creed cosplay on.
Trish?
They put all the NPC people in hoods so they wouldn't have to animate their hair.
That's so smart.
Oh yes, we have the warrior guys.
They are being controlled.
So they are like...
Yeah, it's all staged.
Wow,
he's putting on a good show.
I'm not gonna lie.
Change!
Changing from Nero to Dante carries over your vitality, DT gauge, proud souls and all orbs and items obtained.
All proud souls will be refunded and can be reused to acquire techniques specifically for Dante.
They made the demon problem so they could sell the divine solution.
Yeah, pretty much.
I'm not that into Zodiacs, but are my Zodiacs cursed or blessed?
My Lunar Animal Zodiac year is the Snake and my Constellation Zodiac month is Cancer.
I don't know anything about Zodiacs.
If you're a snake, it's probably a good thing.
Will you start accidentally calling Dante Nero?
Right!
Oh no!
What?
This is the worst...
This is the worst outfit I've damn ever seen.
It doesn't suit him at all.
It's so bad.
Spardante?
It looks like he should be in Castlevania.
Oh, it's so bad.
Why the... I think it wouldn't be less bad with the monocle.
It's so bad.
I feel like I have to.
Try not to spoil... How long do I get to play as Dante?
As a killer Zodiac guy, I can tell you that everything is going to be just fine.
Miles Edgeworth?
No, no, no.
This is not Miles Edgeworth.
This is... What's his name?
Von Karma.
A while.
For a while?
OK, then I'm going to play.
Come to grips with the power... I didn't press anything.
Come to grips with the power of the legendary Devil Hunter.
Oh, I did not mean to press that.
That's my fault.
Let's do this one and then I think I'm... It's like, are you sure?
It's giving me... It's like, are you sure you want this outfit?
It's giving me a second chance.
OK, for the first mission I'll use normal Dante.
Oh, my bad.
There we go.
For the first mission I'll use normal Dante.
OK.
Player change.
This is so bad.
We will use that costume at some point.
Rebellion!
Press and hold Y.
Oh my gosh!
Sure.
That's all I have?
Coyote A.
Stinger my beloved!
Oh he also has a charge shot.
What do we have for DT though?
Trigger heart.
Oh, that's good.
We don't have very much though.
Speed!
Enemy step?
Oh, air hike!
No!
Oh no!
Wait, I'm going to refund this one.
Maybe we can get all of them to at least...
I don't even use Royal Guard.
I didn't use it before.
Not to sound spoilery, but the Sparta costume is hilarious for a certain cutscene.
Hopefully it's not this route.
This mission.
Gun, sword, gun, trick, gun, bomb, gun, gun...
I use the trickster a lot because...Oh my god.
Holy...Oh my god.
Winning game, please spam the D-pad for peek view.
What does he call it out?
Does he be like sword, sword, gun, trickster, sword, gun master, sword, trickster, gun, sword master...
He dies?
Oh geez.
Wow, look at him go.
What is four?
Oh that's what he did to me.
That's what he did to me.
No.
Nah, we'll hold on to guns later.
Maybe we'll do trickster.
Trickster four.
Oh gosh.
This.
You, you, you.
They just gave me a little taste of what was to come.
Oh my god.
I already bought double heart.
I already bought it.
Or, oh no, I bought trigger heart.
What's devil heart?
Wait, what's that one?
Remember, this is the first DMC where you can swap styles with the D-pad and not at the start of levels.
True, you're so right.
Oh, trigger, it is trigger heart.
I bought it.
I bought it already.
You're too, you're too slow.
Shall we...
Start...
By pressing D-pad, Dante can change his fighting style on the fly.
Changing style will change the effect of...
During battle.
Proud souls are more for Dante than Dero.
True, right.
Oh my god.
Can't
be grabbed anymore.
Oh my gosh, it's crazy.
Crazy.
Oh my god.
Turn it down a little bit.
Oh, Stinger.
Stinger, I miss you.
Oh, you're so good.
You work so well.
DT Stinger.
You're right.
Oh!
Is he
good?
There he is.
Oh, wow.
It's so silly.
I'm such a fan.
Come on.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, we are so bad.
Kinda gonna miss grabby grab though.
Did I go the right way?
Wait, was there anywhere else in this room?
Oh my god!
It feels so nostalgic for some reason.
We've only been a little bit with Nero, but even still I'm just like, wow.
It just feels right.
It's gonna be really difficult for me though to...
To remember stuff.
Maybe not.
Maybe it'll come like second nature, you know?
But it's really hard not to just spam Stinger, I'll be honest.
Trickster.
You can hold that spinny move, I can.
Oh, what lies ahead has already been raised.
There's no... Oh.
Okay, I was going the right way.
I'm a DMC casual and I'm proud.
I will spam Stinger.
I'm proud.
I love it.
Playing Dante in this game for the first time felt like coming home after a long trip.
Right!
Wait, is this different now?
Oh no, I'm still Nero.
Nevermind.
Please be gentle with Dante.
If you spam his voice lines too much you'll have a headache and be sad.
I don't think so.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, I don't like that at all.
Some pants.
Is it a certain little lady?
Perhaps.
Oh no, it's his pants.
Damn, when are we going to see ladies?
I already missed Grabby Grab, I'm not going to lie.
Holy cow.
Oh, it's too good.
Oh, I'm on Trickster, that's right.
Holy...
Oh, I thought I killed him.
It's been so long.
I just can't... I want to spam it.
Tag!
Get washed!
Good old Stinger spam.
Never... never fails.
He is so fast, right?
He's so fast.
DT Stinger eats up the DT gauge.
Got it.
I didn't notice that it didn't last very long.
Understood.
Are there still lasers?
Oh, this isn't the laser room.
Oh, I got the wing talisman.
One of the idols is taking a nap.
Sleep for me, Dante.
His odors and his stamina issues.
It's okay.
lol
He's doing that meme.
The Pulp Fiction meme.
Come on.
Sleep for me, Dante.
Sleep for me.
Sleep, pussy.
You're tired.
You're getting sleepy.
This is what I do to my cat, okay?
When my cat is trying to sleep, I go...
Are you tired?
Do you want to go to Dream Town?
Is the sound of my voice making you sleepy?
Do you want to chase some mice in your dreams?
Do you want to go to Dream Town?
Do you want to go to sleep?
Are your eyelids getting heavy?
Do you want to go chase mice in your dreams?
This isn't my tag!
I'm gonna stop.
God's power no longer resides here.
Headquarters has begun to collapse.
That doesn't seem very good.
You have less than 10 minutes to escape.
But what about all the rorbs?
Okay, I'll leave.
I won't be greedy.
I'll be a little greedy.
Wait.
I think I messed up.
Where is the opening?
Where is Dante?
Oh, dang it!
You guys!
I didn't see that one coming.
That was a lower barrier.
What does that mean?
Oh my god, please die!
Die!
Okay, time to go.
Please?
You guys are too fat.
Alright.
Oh, but...
I think I have enough time.
I didn't
get it before, so it's only fair I get it now.
You'll be fine.
Really?
No!
Oh no.
Wait, can I not grabby grab the guys?
Oh gosh.
Change gun.
LT.
Press LT to change your long range gun.
Okay.
I love DMC2!
I
love DMC2!
We made it!
Yeah!
This thing?
Make it stop!
Oh, we made it faster.
Oh no!
Oh yeah!
Overheat!
Overload!
There we go.
Perfect!
Key of Kronos!
I have to make sure I leave out the correct one.
Shirley's.
Okay.
Yeah, it's this one.
Nice.
Oh, you.
It worked!
Ouch.
Ouchy ouch.
Ouchy ouchy ouchy ouch.
Oh come on.
That's so unfair.
Unfair.
Trickster might help.
Oh, I was on Trickster.
Oh, thank you.
You're right.
Trickster big help.
Trickster big help!
Let's go.
And grab some...
Roll orbs while we're at it.
Maybe we don't need it.
There is nothing in here.
I saw...I saw...I saw a purple devil.
Oh nice!
Nice!
Oh come on!
No!
I did it.
Somehow.
Dante is so strong.
Oh, it wasn't purple.
It was a stinking thing.
I don't think there is anything else here, right?
There are some chairs.
How far do I need to get away from the exploding place?
Uh oh.
Ok.
Nice!
Yeah!
See ya!
Not that far apparently.
We just went outside.
We had so much time.
Dante look!
Oh look at you!
Look at you!
You're so handsome.
Pose with him.
All his little mannerisms are all the same.
It's so nice.
He even goes to break down and everything is all the same.
It's so comfortable.
Yeah!
We're running.
I'm still running.
Nice scenery.
Pizza!
Lady!
Pizza on Friday!
Exactly.
Everyone is still hanging out.
They worship a demon as a god?
Yeah.
They're a wolf.
Not my pizza.
So?
She looks good in that suit.
Is that a suit?
What do you call it?
In that blazer coat and nothing else.
Trish?
Oh my god.
I want some pizza.
See you there!
He was just reminiscing.
Ladies!
Not bad.
A for A!
One second though.
I'll show my YouTube pros.
Nice.
One second.
Why is YouTube always so weird?
Nice.
Well guys, I think I might actually call it here.
It's a little... It's not so many...
Not so many missions, but I'm feeling so...
I need to get some sleep for real tonight.
And I actually didn't have dinner, so...
I'm sorry that it's a bit shorter of a stream.
My next mission might be longer, so this is a good point.
Cool.
Three missions, three bosses is solid.
Yeah.
I like that there was more cutscenes in this one too.
Because I like just watching how they're all so silly.
The anime lady often comes up with excuses to keep Dante deep in debt to her.
She's so tsundere maybe.
Why is DMC2 depressed of Dante suddenly going to...
Off the church and running to the new protag and silly pulling him out of his bunk.
Yeah, more DMC4 next week, so...
But it will not be on Friday.
So, it will be a different day.
Obviously, you'll see it when I have the schedule out.
Thank you guys for more DMC today.
And I will...
Oh, there we go.
I'm just going to go to the mission menu.
I am so tired.
But I've got to get some sleep and tomorrow is Peace Walker.
I've got to be energized for that.
And I have another collab tomorrow night.
Still deciding if I'm going to have my POV for that.
We'll see.
I might embarrass myself with my Nihongo.
I hate speaking Nihongo.
I can understand, but I hate speaking.
So, I'm self-conscious.
I have no confidence.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Sumimasari.
It's because I always get so psyched out.
I can't remember how to speak or words or anything.
I don't have many opportunities to speak.
I don't know, maybe this is good practice.
I mean, well, it is good practice.
I don't know.
Anyway, I'm going to...
My brain is done-zo for now.
That's just me normally.
Yeah, who's in the collab?
It's Coyote from Kemono Friends.
Milky.
I'm excited I get to collab with her before she graduates.
I have confidence.
Nekomiya Hinata.
It's also a bunch of people I don't know too, so I'm like...
Nervous, nervous.
Ayami Mama, of course.
Ayami Mama is in there too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I'm excited to meet new people.
Otsumito, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And I will see you.
Oh, no Henya.
I don't think Henya this time.
Thanks for the stream.
Such a busy week.
Be sure to get some good sleep.
Thank you!
Minto Nihongo teaching stream?
No.
I'm no sensei.
I need to go back to school.
Ok, Otsumito.
Thank you everyone.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye bye.
Have a good day.